queste menti
[Applauso]
si no
raga mi stavo giusto chiedendo quanto
sono interessanti i programmi giapponesi
quindi mi sono sdraiato sul letto che ho
utilizzato su tele comando né per
accendere il televisore che ci ha di
fianco primocanale primo che ho visto è
questo una partita di hi tech che è un
gioco simile alla dama sono tutto
emozionato e adrenalina drena limitato
ad esso
mamma mia che che programmi coinvolgenti
che non mi addormento mica cambiamo
canale vediamo cosa riusciamo a trovare
in questa televisione giapponese
bellissima otto e più lato bisogna
vedere come la televisione giapponese
sasha che divertentissimo e beh questa è
barbara d'urso giapponese è trento
schiaffi in faccia si vuole 30 scatti
faccia io io io in faccia in faccia
quando la tipa guardati pala tipo non
sta capendo niente che stai a caso che
cazzo come passare il sabato pomeriggio
nel migliore dei modi la gara ad
aumentare questo porca vacca nicolò di
zuri questo
macché perché c'è una cipolla di cannara
che io non capisco la pubblicità
giappone non le capisco è il nuovo tipo
di censura di facce perché non c'era
voglia di censurarla in modo figo allora
poi non ci abbiamo voglia mettere un
punto interrogativo sulla faccia mamma
mia è brutto ma le due si scaccola
grazie che ci ha portato al parco papà
di nulla grazie mandarin altra parte no
no papà che bambini bambini escono con
tre piedi la cayman era un bambino che
era entrato a stanno pure la portano a
casa
ci sono i bambini che si divertono e poi
ci siamo noi che cazzo vuoi guarda là
qualche casino
quante bolle che ha avuto l'ottima idea
di venire qua bene grazie salvo
leggermente caldo c'è un sacco di gente
e non riusciremo anche a respirare
allora cosa è una è stata stretta
c'è tanta gente si non c'è un bel tira
vento in realtà alle palle storia tengo
sembra che una costola della cia ragazzi
volevo dirvi una cosa che fa troppo
ridere e noi quest'anno il giappone
siamo tornati esattamente dopo un anno e
siamo tornati nella stessa casa dovevamo
stati l'anno scorso perché c'erano
trovati bene l'anno scorso dormivo là
dove quest'anno dormono sapri e sascha
quest'anno qui questo questo ho detto
qua questa è la mia roba
l'anno scorso sono venuto qui e avevo il
libro si vede anche nel logo l'anno
scorso libro del draw my life
me lo sono dimenticati in questa casa
cui quando sono partite mi sono
dimenticato che ha detto cazzo ho perso
il sudore ha promesso che siamo tornati
un anno dopo in questa casa
attraversando il corridoio stamattina
guardo i libri qua sotto e tra i libri
giapponesi di sta minkia il draw mylife
dell'anno scorso è rimasto un anno in
questa casa in giappone sono venuta a
riprendermi e proprio lo stesso perché
gestito carlo conti si apre una pagina a
caso c'è scritto non mi ricordo cosa ho
mangiato a pranzo giuseppe dorme e io
credo che ad esso appartenga al giappone
quindi lo rilascio qua dopo un anno
intero tassato in questa battuta
libreria di due centimetri quadri praga
nuovo episodio di dark souls
questo è il boss in questo ha rivelato
io credo che sia il mio il mio incubo
più grande questa cosa che sto vedendo
fare stato in memoria di ragni che
devono bruciare tutti i vivi come fare
una statua in memoria di hitler che
cazzo serve in chiusura di questo blog i
ragazzi tranne che i miei capelli non li
ho tagliati per due settimane e sono
partito che ci avevo già una foresta in
testa è in questo momento non so a che
stadio di super sayan sono arrivato
abbiamo cambiato casa e siamo
nell'ultima casa per l'ultima settimana
di giappone e ve la faccio vedere per la
faccia in breve ragazze talmente grossa
questa casa che diversamente da dove
stavamo prima perché avete visto ho
letto questa stanza qui che vedete è
solo la mia c'è io ho due letti chiede
una per lui e l'altro per melo e gli ho
dato quello che grosso la vista è uno di
quelle tipiche giapponesi che non si sa
dove minchia sei finito procede filo
spinato qua in basso
sperando di non svegliare nessuno visto
che mattina vi faccio vedere il resto
della casa
per questo per piano di sopra che il
bagno
credo che sia la cosa più scadente di
tutta la casa perché c'è questo che non
ho idea di che cosa sia
c'è poco non so che cosa stravinca è la
vasca eccesso fanno abbastanza schifo
considerando che nell'altra casa eccesso
di spruzzava l'acqua nel culo e adesso
andiamo al piano di sotto
ma che ha sì è vero che pirla per
aprirla non ci vuole la chiave è
stranissimo questa la porta di casa per
aprirla devi tirare su questo caso e
inserire il codice 06 10 asterisco da la
cia si deve solo spostate poi quando la
chiudi si blocca la sola fighissima sta
roba comunque queste l'atrio questi sono
i pupazzi credo tutti di sabrina questa
è la sala da pranzo dove abbiamo anche
qui fatto la parte della cia
questa è la banana di sasha che mi
mangerò io adesso questo il salone manca
solo la cucina che è questa qui che ha
una chicca che voi non avete idea
la cucina ragazza una cosa incredibile
questo che state vedendo e il
frigorifero no questa è la maniglia e
fino qui però se io faccio così
sì è proprio quello che pensate come
come è bellissimo c'è in base si aprirà
tutte e due le parti è incredibile non
ho mai visto il frigo così è la goduria
perché italia si approda una parte un
all'attacco si apre a tutte e due le
parti questo è un signor frigo e come
ultima cosa c'è la lavatrice che c'era
anche nella prima casa con la kyoto si
chiama big big drum quindi grande
batteria e ieri ci ho messo i miei
vestiti
ovviamente non ho sotto i fazzoletti dai
vestiti quindi osmin chiato tutto non
fate vedere questo video giuseppe grazie
controllare sempre di non lasciare i
fazzoletti quando fai la lavatrice
quanti ne avevo di fazzoletti alla
madonna quanti fazzoletti avevo guarda
che casino ma basta ragazzi di dire che
possono dire di questo video usciranno
ancora due blog sul giappone in questa
settimana vi sia piaciuto cosa momento
mi piace anche parecchio mia dedizione
vi faccio salutare da papa ha salutato
un blog uscire
e cazzo ai sordi
[Musica]